ronald mcdaniel rnc chairwoman joins me
now rana why is this so difficult we're
looking at something
that we know is not right we're dealing
with a communist country who was not
forthright honest and transparent
at the very beginning of the pandemic
well you think of how many lives have
been lost how many of us have lost loved
ones and friends
and to see this cover-up being aided by
the biden administration for them to
shut down
a credible investigation to go to the
whao who was so ineffective
from the very beginning in in
identifying this pandemic
and also they've had a year to
investigate they haven't
i think it's really shameful and i agree
with rand paul we need to get to the
bottom of this but i don't know if this
is the
administration that can do that because
they're part of the cover-up right now
i'll move to this the republican
governors association is pointing a
finger now
at michigan democrat gretchen whitmer
for violating her own
coveted restrictions again this time
she took a secret flight to florida
while residents of her state were locked
down under pandemic travel advisories
the association is taking aim at whitmer
and a new ad
here it is gretchen whitmer secretly
flew to florida to visit her father
i wish i had that same chance but
whitmer
closed nursing homes when we tried to
say goodbye the day that he died
the facility called the police we have
ignored our own rules
while the rest of us were forced to
comply
what's your reaction to that well one my
heart aches
for that family for so many families who
can't get answers from the whitmer
administration as to what happened with
the nursing homes
but then the sheer hypocrisy for her to
say you can't go visit your loved ones
and then she lies about taking a trip to
florida
taking a private plane it really is
shameful and it shows why
she's going to have a tough reelection
next year we're going to
change that governorship to republican
because of the many many failures and
hypocrisy of gretchen whitmer in
michigan
you know before i let you go real
quickly why is there at least a mini
trend line we don't know if it'll be
bigger than that
uh with democratic governors on this
issue of nursing homes
i mean look i'm in a state too in new
jersey governor murphy did the same
thing
we didn't have the carnage that they did
in new york city but then you've got
whitmer
yeah i mean she's not being forthcoming
so you can't get the nursing home data
out of michigan we don't have
foia laws that allow that and she has
covered up everything with ndas with
letting people go
there's a lot here in michigan that that
the citizens don't know
because of a governor who hasn't led and
is hiding and covering up her tracks
chairwoman ronald mcdaniel thank you
very much good to see you
thanks for having me